oh my so little time so many questions
peyton i'm coming your way first was
there any particular scene in season
five where it was most difficult to
reflect all of the layers of torrey's
situation the connection to kris
pretending to be a good student at cobra
kai and also conveying how she's really
feeling about what she's doing
perry yes every
day every single scene i just thought
how could someone balance all this how
am i hiding this am i hiding this well
is tori a good actress what's happening
like i just felt like there was so much
happening in my head and i was so
overwhelmed and stressed as
the character that
it was it was hard to keep her life
together while knowing i'm a high school
student on top of all that and having my
mother to take care of at home so
there's just a lot for tori worth every
ounce of stress it all comes through
quite beautifully all right show low for
you now so miguel and robbie have
obviously fought before but the one in
the apartment complex definitely feels a
little different to me because it
mirrors a very very specific major
change in their relationship so how does
having a fight like that so heavily tied
to the character's evolution impact your
work when you're tackling the really
difficult stunt work also
hey
you bring up a really great point i
think this was one of the first times in
a while that tanner and i had been able
to fight just the two of us because
usually you know we we've fought almost
every season but usually it's in the
midst of
mary or payton or the whole gang so i
think with this fight it feels a lot
more intimate and a lot more you know
the the need to want to win was was
there for the both of us and i think
uh
it ended up being like one of my
favorite fights that we've done in the
whole show it came out really really
great and uh getting to you know we
filmed it chronologically so by the end
we really were like
okay
i forgive you let's just stop right now
but uh you know tanner's a he's a
he performs so well when it comes to you
know the fights and and it's awesome
getting to to work alongside him so i'm
glad that we're on the same side now at
least for at least for the moment is it
very rare for you to film a fight scene
like that chronologically um
i'd say
the
i don't know if it's rare i think it's
we're so used to doing stuff out of
order that sometimes it feels a little
refreshing to be like all right we got
that piece now this is the next piece
this this and this but no usually it's
usually it's not necessarily in order
that's one thing that turns my brain to
mush i don't know how you guys do your
jobs in general but when you like mush
everything together then it's just like
i can't even process it
uh
another stunt question i'll throw your
way jacob so this might be me
overthinking things a little bit but
hawk has been involved in a whole lot of
stunts where he is the powerhouse and
even when he takes hits he bounces right
back and gets right back to it so what's
the difference between selling those
kinds of hits and then selling the one
where kenny punches him with terry's uh
silver bullet yeah that was hard that
was hard for me to like
like pretend that yeah to pretend being
her i was like okay fine
i guess this hurts a lot
it's not physically difficult it was
something yeah i know no it's nice
i'm like hawk would never go down
um
it is i mean it's very different i think
that's sort of part of
hawk's sort of arc this season is you
know he's just off of a huge win and
he's able to take hits and he always
comes back and you know he goes to the
dark side and then comes back to the
good side but
you know i think
now he's facing someone who has this
hidden jutsu that just
you know absolutely paralyzes him and i
think that's hard for him to come to
terms with you know like he freaking
lost and i think he's a little
overconfident in the season and you know
i think that definitely led to i mean
even like the first time uh i fight
dallas like i'm just kind of like
blocking and not really caring and then
i get clocked a little bit you know um i
think that's foreshadowing to him
i got high hopes for a lot more growth
for him in the future this time
gianni so
at this point dimitri has his friends
back he's got his girlfriend he's got a
whole bunch of super cool senseis
whether it's someone in the group that i
just mentioned or maybe someone i'm not
even thinking about who do you think
dimitri would benefit the most from
spending more time with in season six
oh god um i mean you know like you said
yeah dimitri's life is going pretty well
right now that's uh he doesn't have a
lot of drama going around
a lot of that going on in this area um
geez i don't know
i mean i love me personally i love
working with billy a lot oh yeah
with carmen um no i love working with
billy a lot and uh i really like seeing
uh his relationship dimitri's
relationship with johnny uh when he
sells him the phone and now they kind of
have like that softer moment right there
um so i don't know what he could benefit
from that
maybe he'll become a little bit more
badass maybe he'll learn to step outside
of himself a bit more uh it's something
i think johnny does really well so yeah
maybe you could learn a thing or two
from him i would love to watch more
dimitri and johnny it's a they're a
great player my favorite scene yeah
yeah thank you all right i'm going to
try to do and see if someone yells at me
mary i have the time perry sorry i'm
sorry about that i said i think we're
talking again mary that's why i saved
you for left just in case that happens
oh good i'll see you later perry all
right congrats guys see you soon
you